how'd you make sure that I do motorbike
carrying on I can
and we're gonna go and see my boyfriend
he's an artist a street artist
ooping excursion guys go pick that
person you inspire me to do think that
the street still has a rebellious look I
like your brother I like his friends
there they're cool but I just I want you
to know that I'm by your side so you got
robbed it my brother that hope is out
there living
we have graffiti art fetching six-figure
sums in some galleries with the heat or
now boys you better bury yourself this
is a once-in-a-lifetime score
you probably got off the gangs in West
London off yet bring the job before
first thing
Detective Sergeant Baxter from tried him
and became done unit the other loyal
turn cleans evidence the first chance
they get I love you too to stay silent
it's no use to you know he's got the
details or something you might be
interested in I'm glad you don't hang
out with your brother those dudes
nothing pulling you down with customers
they do not pull me that Chris said that
he's good and it's a big jump serious
amount of money to be liked
getting smashing good
you